on this episode of the boys america is
safe
okay it is safe so everyone get out
there go to your restaurants but as you
see it's a beautiful day the beaches are
open and people are having a wonderful
time i didn't love you
i hated you you should be wailing you
stone cold [ __ ]
[Music]
this is a gay bar wait what remember
last episode how we saw mother's milk
and kimiko steal confidential files from
the secret russian lab well it looks
like they were able to retrieve video
too video of soulja boy being tested and
tortured on by the russians we get some
interesting info here like how both his
internal and external tissue is
essentially bulletproof and due to some
sort of procedure soldier boy registers
high amounts of radiation this happened
on january 24th so it likely has nothing
to do with chernobyl this is how butcher
knows soldier boy is near when his
geiger counter goes off the world thinks
soldier boy died stopping a nuclear
reactor from exploding in 1984 but as we
learn in this episode his former lover
crimson countess was complicit in his
capture near the end of the episode
soldier boy confronts the countess
believing it was the russians who paid
her off we never find out who the
mastermind behind this plan was we're
kind of left in the dark that she may
have just done this out of spite but i
think there's a bit more here and my
guess is that stan edgar and vaught
played some part just think of it from
their perspective if the russians were
able to stop superheroes like how we saw
soldier boy nullify kimiko's powers they
could then pose a threat to u.s hegemony
and yes i googled that word to sound
smart currently no country dare defy
america what with their abundance of
superheroes and arguably strongest
weapon homelander but if the russians
could stop supes war could ignite and
vaunt could make heaps of money loaning
their superheroes to the us government
remember the reason stan edgar was in
south america to begin with was to do a
trial run of superheroes being used in
combat something that hadn't been done
for 30 years supes in the military has
been something stan edgar has wanted
since season one but crimson countess
working with vaught to bring down
soldier boy also serves a personal
purpose yes they were a couple but his
flirting with grace mallory suggests he
was a womanizer and his edited comments
from his don't do drugs campaign show he
was a drug addict and verbally abusive
this is hot
[Applause]
it's [ __ ] unprofessional the video
also shows us what appears to be soldier
boy's only weakness halothane a general
anesthetic seen here in gas form butcher
brings a few canisters of this with them
to crimson countess's trailer just in
case they need to use it we also get our
first look at kimiko who wasn't looking
too hot at the end of last episode where
it was discovered her powers have
stopped working butcher's lack of caring
for her has caused a rift between him
and mother's milk you don't give a [ __ ]
about camiko his decision to take temp v
is to quote level the playing field but
mm reminds him why the boys exist in the
first place so that no one should have
that kind of power it's here butcher has
a hallucination of a young boy build in
the credits as teen we saw him a few
episodes ago when butcher is about to
take temp fee for the first time my best
guess is that this is butcher's dead
brother lenny in season 2 butcher's
father sam blames butcher for lenny's
death that he left him to join the
british sas and wasn't there for lenny
when he needed him most considering all
the shots of this boy are followed by
voiceover of huey the writers are trying
to parallel lenny with huey huey has
become a sort of younger brother to
butcher whether he likes it or not and
being there for huey might be some form
of redemption for him and
congratulations to ashley nominated as
the new ceo of vaude talk about a
meteoric rise to one of the biggest
companies in the world no doubt this is
homelanders doing he knows he can easily
control her but this first board meeting
doesn't go over as planned considering
homelanders complete lack of business
knowledge he doesn't know the first
thing about running a company we'll even
see how he completely fumbles the
handling of soldier boy's first attack
if this is how things are starting maybe
stan edgar was right that the people
will come to see how bad of a person
homelander really is back in crime
analytics the deep has been promoted to
head of the division a division he'll
ask most of its members when it's found
out they all had views on social media
critical of vaught there is one survivor
however you might remember anika who
once offered black noir in almond joy
there's one on her desk and even huey
has one in his apartment with starlight
of note here is cassandra once again
pulling the deep strings mouthing all
the words to his planned out speech no
doubt written by her and just how the
deep is gonna cover his job fight crime
and promote his new movie not without my
dolphin which you can see the trailer
for on vaught's youtube channel is
beyond me in truvat fashion super
sonic's death has been covered up
calling it an overdose huey easily opens
a jar of smuckers which back in episode
1 he needed starlight's help and he
comes clean about his use of compound v
seeing he's done taking it so that was a
[ __ ] lie hughie is really sabotaging
his own relationship with starlight
keeping secrets from her when he said
there would be no more secrets and not
telling her about his eventual sting
operation with butcher and soldier boy
this relationship is not looking good
meanwhile soldier boy seems to have
found a flight from russia back to
america as we'll see him later in new
york exploding when triggered by some
delightful russian music this whole
event makes me wonder if this triggering
could be exploited by any of the others
butcher looks over his necklace of saint
christopher which was the necklace he
gave to ryan and was subsequently thrown
away for more info on its meaning check
out my season 2 video maeve has arrived
with more vials of temp v with
homelander having a clamp on things at
vaude i wonder if her stealing of these
vials will pop up on his radar i mean
there's got to be someone at vod who's
like hey we've lost a half dozen vials
of our top secret soup serum with the
russia job a bust maeve and butcher
discuss the alternatives the plane video
won't do them any good homelander will
just go on a rampage and ryan is still
too young to take on his dad so butcher
does what anyone with nothing to do does
take a trip to maeve's inclusive kingdom
and all i can think is let's just say
that maeve can bend a steel pipe without
using her hands little nina is pissed
about what happened in russia with 10
dead russian soldiers and a classified
lab destroyed frenchie is now in her
debt and in order to pay this debt he
must kill pyotar simanov and his
daughter katarina we aren't quite sure
who they are nor if it's integral to the
plot i just left a little nina blow
smoke in this guy's face this is all bad
news for frenchie who just last episode
told kimiko he'd leave with her after
this final job it'll be interesting to
see what he ends up doing in the
background of the hallway at vaught
tower you can make out a silver kincaid
and crimson countess poster silver
kincaid was one of the finalists in
american hero the reality tv show where
homelander announced he was dating
starlight in this super short scene
pardon the pun starlight digs deep into
eight train for ratting them out to
homelander and getting super sonic
killed why are you so desperate to be
with people who hate you this is all
part of atran's character arc this
season discovering who he really is in
the next scene a train is given the
opportunity to talk with bluehawk the
soup accused of targeting black
communities for his reality tv show red
white and blue justice this meeting was
allowed by homelander as a thank you for
turning in super sonic and exposing
starlight's plan a train wants a public
apology from bluehawk and what better
place than in a community he was accused
of discriminating against there he
surprises his brother with bluehawk's
appearance and bluehawk could not give a
[ __ ] about being there the whole apology
is a sham with bluehawk increasingly
getting riled up and eventually taking
his anger out on the people one of whom
is a train's brother who will later see
in the hospital and who will never walk
again this raises the stakes for a train
it's now personal will he finally stand
up to homelander and bluehawk or will he
as starlight said be desperate to be
with the people who hate him i love the
added touch of congratulations flowers
in the background one of them from us
senator lindsey graham who she calls a
gooch licker and who in real life was
accused of sucking up to trump as soon
as he won the republican nomination i
really like this scene where soldier boy
takes in his surroundings in new york
remember the guy hasn't been out in the
real world in nearly 40 years so seeing
an openly gay couple and adds like queen
maeve show your true colors are a bit
weird for him i also like the robert
singer and ted cruz 2024 presidential
posters mother's milk is upset when he
finds janine's stepdad todd is letting
his daughter watch propaganda about
homelander he knows how vot manipulates
the media to make their corrupt supes
look like heroes his grandfather died in
a car crash likely caused by an impaired
soldier boy but as we saw in one of mm's
newspaper clippings it was covered up to
make it look like soldier boy was a hero
todd has drunk the vaught kool-aid we
saw him dress up as homelander for
janine's birthday and giddy is a
schoolgirl when homelander made his
unhinged speech meanwhile hughie and
butcher investigate the aftermath of
soldier boy's attack on 59th street the
radiation in the area is off the charts
but this scene is really meant to bring
mother's milk back into the fold he
wants to stop soldier boy but knows he
can't do it on his own if there's any
chance of success he'll need to team up
the boys who are really getting the hang
of taking this temp v something he very
much disapproves of thankfully mm has a
lead the legend former vp of hero
management at vaught before madeleine
stilwell this character was teased on
the official the boy's twitter account
and if you zoom in you can even see they
put the actor's name who plays him
hidden in the picture it was him who
covered up what soldier boy did to
mother's milk's family his apartment is
filled with all sorts of memorabilia
from photos with bert reynolds carrie
fisher steve mcqueen dennis hopper and
roy scheider if i got any of those names
wrong let me know i didn't grow up in
the 80s there are even some cool movie
posters like this means noir crimson a
budweiser ad starring soldier boy and
payback which i'm assuming stars the
members of our team we met down in south
america and for all you horndogs out
there here are pictures of shannon tweed
and kelly lebrock just two of the women
the legend well you know now the legend
is hesitant on helping the boys after
all the last time he tried to help he
lost his leg in an undercover hooker
sting trying to bring down a soup named
electra shock but he ends up divulging
that soldier boy came to pick up his
super suit and that he wanted the
address of his girlfriend crimson
countess maeve watches homelander quell
the fears of the american people after
the recent terrorist attack by soldier
boy these storm chasers stormfront's
fanatical white supremacy-oriented
followers have already said the attack
was by stan edgar to discredit
homelander but maeve is interrupted by
jon yes maeve uses the name homelander
was called by the doctor who raised him
jonah vogelbaum which i found to be
quite interesting homelander talks about
how she and her used to be good together
but she says she hated him from the
start this is almost exactly the same
thing crimson countess says about her
relationship with soldier boy maeve is
then attacked by black noir who probably
wants to get back at her for almost
killing him with an almond joy last
season butcher and huey make the
decision to take more temp v which mm
doesn't approve of if you don't draw the
line somewhere
how the hell are you gonna know where
you stand but butcher says their enemies
don't have a line i ain't drawing that
line starlight confronts ashley about
maeve's whereabouts it's the global
wellness retreat of course which if
you've been following bot news is the
place supes go for rehab but starlight
knows ashley is full of [ __ ] and in a
moment of weakness she admits she's
scared this is one of those make or
break scenes for ashley's character with
her ultimately siding with homelander
and telling starlight to take a hike
this likely means something really bad
is in ashley's future i do think maeve
is still alive this might even be her in
the background of a future fight scene
against soldier boy found in the trailer
kimiko and frenchie are watching the
1943 film girl crazy starring the wizard
of oz's judy garland it's the beginning
of a fantastic musical dream sequence
where kimiko gets her voice back these
dreams of reclaiming her voice started
back in episode 1 where she sings dream
a little dream again the attention to
detail here is amazing we have bedpans
being used as drums defibrillators
sparking and even superhero posters in
the background like black noir's be a
hero give blood unfortunately the dream
can't last and when frenchie goes for
coffee he's caught by nina and her thug
nina's been trying to get a hold of him
since he was supposed to have taken out
that dude and his kid meanwhile at the
future grounds of chimp country crimson
countess's refuge for apes i guess she's
had to resort to camming to pay for this
big project only 1950 a minute and she's
camping with none other than seth rogen
or should i say sir comes alot 779 i'm
pretty sure seth is playing himself in
this scene he's one of the executive
producers of the boys and he also
mentions he once worked with a monkey
from outbreak huey and butcher end up
using crimson countess as bait for
soldier boy tying up her hands since her
powers don't work unless they're put
together throwing a wrench in the plan
is starlight who unbeknownst to huey was
asked to come by mother's milk huey has
not only not told starlight about his
extremely dangerous plan but he's also
taken temp v again something he told her
he wouldn't do huey wants to feel like
he can save starlight for once but what
he needs to understand is that's not
what starlight wants i don't need you to
save me huey
i need you meanwhile butcher roofied
mm's water knowing mm would never have
gone along with their partnership with
soldier boy so soldier boy arrives with
his old suit and a dapper new shave and
one of the things this show does so well
in establishing is empathy for unlikable
characters i actually felt a little bit
sad for soldier boy when he said the one
thing he clung to all those years was
the hope that crimson countess would
come and rescue him and when he learns
the truth that crimson countess was
complicit in his capture he burns her to
a crisp but the episode ends on a big
decision by huey go with starlight or go
with butcher and soldier boy hughie
believes he needs to team up with
soldier boy for the greater good to take
down homelander and part of huey's
character arc this season is realizing
the only way you can take down vaught
and these corrupt supes is by stooping
to their level i thought we could
fight about the right way but we can't
it's all rigged if we're gonna take them
down
we have to do whatever it takes even
though huey thinks he's doing this to
save starlight from homelander it's not
what starlight wants and this is now the
third episode in a row that ends on a
close-up of starlight leading me to
believe something really big is gearing
up for her character i would not be
surprised if starlight dies this season
or someone dies trying to save her it
would be ironically tragic if huey's
efforts to save starlight actually end
up getting her killed i mean the writers
have been telegraphing this save quite a
bit let me save you for once this is the
only way that i can save you from
homelander i can finally save you for
once in the trailer we see starlight
eventually fighting soldier boy
alongside mother's milk so it'll be
interesting if we kind of have three
factions at war here butcher and huey
with soldier boy starlight and mother's
milk and homelander and vaught
whatever's in store for us [ __ ] is
definitely gonna hit the fan thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
[Music]
such a good slicker